YOU KNOW, I THINK WE NEED A WORD
BLERD.
>> WORD BLERD!
>> OKAY.
TONIGHT'S WORD IS "RAPIST."
A RAPIST IS A PERSON WHO COMMITS
AN UNLAWFUL SEXUAL ACT WITH OR
WITHOUT FORCE ON ANOTHER PERSON
WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT.
AND A PERSON WHO IS PHYSICALLY
OR MENTALLY INCAPACITATED
WHETHER BY ALCOHOL, DRUGS OR
ASLEEP IS UNABLE TO
GIVE CONSENT.
WHEN YOU GIVE A WOMAN QUAALUDES
TO KNOCK HER OUT THAT'S WHAT YOU
ARE DOING AND EVEN IF YOU CALL
THE QUAALUDES CUTESY NAMES LIKE
DISCO BISCUITS, AS COSBY DID
IN HIS DEPOSITION I AM NOT
MAKING THIS (BLEEP) UP, IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
I DON'T CARE IF HE CALLS THEM
ROCK 'N' ROLL SCONES OR JAZZ
CRUMPETS, IT IS STILL RAPE.
ALL RIGHT?
>> Larry: NOW, A RAPIST MAY
BELIEVE THEY'RE JUST A PLAYBOY
BUT  A RAPIST
USES SEX TO ASCERTAIN POWER
OVER THEIR VICTIMS TO TAKE WHAT
THEY BELIEVE WHAT THEY DESERVE.
WHEN OF COURSE WHAT THEY
ACTUALLY DESERVE IS TO ROT IN
JAIL.
AND BY DENYING THEIR VICTIMS
THEIR SEXUAL AGENCY, A RAPIST
INCREASES THEIR OWN DELUDED
SENSE OF SELF-WORTH, WHICH IS
WHY A RAPIST CAN TELL SOMEONE
ELSE TO PULL UP THEIR PANTS,
EVEN THOUGH HE HIMSELF NEVER
DID.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: BUT IF YOU STILL
CONFUSED AND YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
ANOTHER DEFINITION OF THE WORD
RAPIST, IT IS PRETTY SIMPLE.
JUST READ THE PAPER.
THIS HAS BEEN WORD BLERD.